[Music]
okay we get 2349 okay a very very good
player who has won all of his 15minute
games but okay let's give it a shot all
right let's go ahead with E4
C5 all right let's roll out the alipin
Knight F6 C5 Knight D5 Knight F3 D6 okay
so here in this position
the traditional MO is to play D4 but in
the alip and chessable
course they um I forget who the authors
are I think it's gen Gully and km janov
they recommend a really interesting idea
that I think kind of revives the line
and that's a check on B5 and to like
understand the power of this check you
need to be familiar with some of the
theory of this line and particularly
with one very important tactic which
might happen because Bishop D7 is the
most popular response now we drop back
to C4 yeah exactly Caucasian Andy
actually knows this idea if the Knight
drops back to B6 which is a very natural
move Knight B6 hitting the bishop you
have this trick Bishop takes F7 check
King takes F7 and most people associate
that with Knight G5 but Knight G5 is
wrong okay we we're we get this Knight
G5 is wrong King G8 is a dead end now
then you might say well wait a minute
what about Queen B3 isn't that mate but
it's not mate black and block with C4 if
you play Knight G5 and then E6 the
bishop moves back to E8 so you actually
have to start with E6 check and
amazingly the pawn is well it's not
Untouchable but if black takes it with
the King black gets checkmated by force
with Knight G5 check and the king is
kind of driven out into the open if
black takes it with the bishop then
obviously still Knight G5 check and you
win back the piece with a slight
Advantage this is not a winning line
a lot of times when you play a line like
this you you kind of hope that you're
winning at the end of it but white is a
slight Advantage at the end of this line
black okay he takes on E6 okay Knight G5
check and King F6 wait a second now King
F6 here of course I don't remember
exactly what the line is I have to think
I know that this is that this is bad for
black I know that this is supposed to be
supposed to be losing but of course I
don't remember exactly how I feel like
it's Queen F3 but I have to
calculate I'm 99% sure it's Queen F3 so
Queen
F3 yeah you could also play a slow move
here you could just push like D4 for
example because the black king is not
really the black king is kind of in a
box so often times in these types of
situations you want to play a move that
just like solidifies your position and
allows you to go for the long run attack
okay so let's calculate Queen F3 if King
takes G5 H4 King G 6 we push H5 King H6
is forced now we push D4 Discovery
G5 takes on pant then he goes King back
to G7 and it looks like black escapes so
let's do this again check takes H4 back
H5 to the side um do we have any other
checks there other than D4 ah we have
Queen E3 that's mate okay I spotted mate
there Queen F3 Queen F3 King takes G5 H4
I think is forced mate although then
wait King H6 immediately no then Queen
F4 is mate so yeah there's mate after
Queen F3 but the problem is Queen F3
Bishop F5 is annoying but if black plays
Bishop F5 maybe we can go either G4
either G4 or we could go D4 it's hard to
say if we should go D4 in this my two
big candidate moves are D4 and queen F3
check
and it's like in a classical game I'd
probably take 30 minutes to decide
between them I think we're going to opt
for Queen F3 check because I still seem
to remember that this is the move also
if we push D4 it gives black a chance to
save the bishop and put put it on D5 and
then it's harder for us to activate Our
Queen so Queen F3 check it is okay he
takes if I've calculated correctly it's
forc mate but maybe I have a hole
somewhere H4 I think this is all in the
course actually yeah King H6 so what he
forgot about is this queen F4 check idea
and it's just mate with a pawn the queen
and the Rook that's it 13 move Game King
G6 H5 all Theory by the way resigns yeah
yeah this is the power of the alip in it
it is a very
misrepresented opening it's often
represented as this very like positional
you know
lowkey anti- Sicilian but in reality you
get a lot of a lot of lines like this if
you play the alipin in kind of the
modern treatment so it's really
interesting how the alapin has evolved
originally it was played very
positionally but now there's been all
this these new finds and it's actually a
super exciting tactical opening which is
why I play it in Blitz almost
exclusively along with I also play
Knight F3 uh D6 Bishop B5 check of
course D6 is not forced so let's go
through some Theory this was a 12 move
game so you might be thinking all right
let's just move on but this is a chance
for us to delve into some Theory um and
hopefully for me to save you a um maybe
on a chessable course because remember
the original point of the speedrun is a
focus on openings and I mean this is the
perfect opportunity to do that so yeah
this is a true speedrun game okay so
first important point is here and we've
had this before but just as a review
notice that I played Knight
F3 the old school move of course is to
immediately play D4
and you might think that there is no
difference because after C takes D4
white typically plays Knight F3 here
which is just something that you have to
know of course the D takes C3 is not
possible so typically here black plays
either Knight C6 or D6 usually Knight C6
and then you get the the the old main
line which is CD D6 Bishop C4 now black
has D takes C5 which equalizes but
Knight B6 is the most popular move by
the way the the same trick does not work
here because the black Bishop is still
undeveloped which paradoxically favors
black obviously here black does not have
to take the pawn but actually black
probably can take the pawn but he can
also drop the king back to G8 simply and
we have no Bishop to
take so here most people play Bishop B5
de Knight takes E5 Bishop D7 this is all
very like very very old Theory Queen
takes D7 Knight C3 E6 castles and in
this position traditionally black was
kind of automatically playing Bishop E7
and does anybody know the most
challenging move here for white which
gives white a small but very nagging
Advantage like if you can guarantee the
black plays Bishop B7 then this line is
perfectly perfectly acceptable yeah very
good people know it Queen G4 Queen G4 is
exactly correct Queen G4 is correct now
black Castle's King side and here
another very important Point uh if you
just excitedly Play Bishop H6 this is a
blunder because black can actually play
Queen takes D4 Knight defends the queen
queen defends the pawn and White's Queen
is hanging so you have to start with
Bishop takes C6 this is a move people
often forget you take the Knight first
black typically takes with a pawn black
can also take with the queen it doesn't
really matter white plays Bishop H6
forcing Bishop F6 now you play Rook fd1
and you basically pre moove the move
Knight E4 even if black steps away from
the pin you can still play Knight E4 all
of this has happened hundreds of times
in OTB chess and obviously if black
takes the bishop you take Black's bishop
and the pawn structure is ruin and white
has a small but stable Advantage it's
like three according to stockfish so
this line is really is really
comfortable for white unfortunately in
like the last 10 years in this position
modern computers have indicated that
Bishop B7 is not only not forced but
there are better moves that equalize
immediately the most incisive one is
just to play A6 and to immediately Force
White's hand so of course typically
white takes on C6 black takes with the
queen and by delaying the development of
the bishop you're taking the sting out
of this queen G4 idea so for example I
think white usually plays Bishop E3 here
black can centralize the Knight and this
is just a dead equal position dead equal
position white is not worse but white
has no Advantage like Rook C1 Bishop B7
and if you play Queen G4 here then black
can eliminate the bishop Bishop before
castling F takes E3 castles and black is
completely fine just equal position so
at a lower level I think this old line
is very very good because a lot of
people still don't know the theory and
they will stumble um as early as like
this position they will play something
weird
or like in this position they'll play
the move E6 which is a viable
alternative but this transposes into a
line that's very promising for
white but at a higher level at the level
that we're at I like the new chessable
well not the new chessable move the the
newer move which is Knight F3 and the
idea is that if black plays Knight C6
our opponent played D6 which is a
completely different line but if black
plays Knight C6 you immediately Play
Bishop C4 you actually skip the move d4
entirely now if black plays E6 now you
play
D4 and generally we transpose to a a
promising line that we just had via the
other move
order but if black drops back to B6 we
drop back to B3 and this leads to a
completely different type of position
that is a lot more tactical it's also a
lot more theoretical you have to know
quite a bit if you want to play this
position with white but in my opinion
it's extremely promising and some cool
new ideas have been found in the main
lines here now I could spend like an
hour and a half talking about the theory
I'll kind of try to summarize it in in
three minutes black has um two main
moves here there's C4 which is very
natural trying to prevent white from
pushing D4 and then there is uh D6 or D5
which is essentially the same thing
because you're going to play on pan and
then typically black plays Queen takes
D6 you castle and one amateur trap is
that if black plays Bishop G4 even GM's
miss this sometimes of course there's
this classic Bishop F7 and Knight G5 so
that's a good perk of this line the main
move is Bishop B6 trading off the light
skirted Bishops and in this position a
new idea was found about a year ago that
like completely rejuvenates the line um
in the old days this position was
considered to be dead equal like there
was absolutely nothing white used to
play D4 automatically and then there
were trades and it was a draw but then
this A4 idea was found and ever since
then black has been in pretty
significant trouble in this line and
I've actually had a speedrun game
exactly with this variation so perhaps
this is familiar to some of you I've
also played this a lot in Blitz the
point is very simple you're trying to
drive this Pawn up to A6 provoking
weaknesses on Black's Queen side so
typically black steps away with the
queen obviously to prepare E6 white
pushes A5 black centralizes the Knight
you push A6 and only now you push D4 and
suddenly you get this very big
initiative in the center and it's very
hard for black to make a move like if
black just
blindly trades everything you centralize
your queen the queen aims at G7 and
makes it very difficult for black to get
the king site out your knight can come
around to C4 you can play Pawn C4 in
some cases Rook D1 so you can explore
this via the other speedrun game I'm
just giving you kind of the executive
summary if black pushes C4 then in this
position once again black can again play
the move
D6 and then you get this very
interesting line and again White's idea
typically is to push A4 and develop the
Knight to A3 as is very standard in the
alipin or black can go after your pawn
and play Queen C7 and here the new idea
is to just sacrifice the pawn and Castle
which is yet again has completely like
rejuvenated this system if black accepts
the sacrifice okay this is like very
high LEL Theory this is why like I
wanted to end the speedrun earlier
because you get into these situations
where if you're a higher rated player
you just have to know know a lot and
things don't necessarily have kind of
internal logic here you play A4 and it
turns out that white is actually much
better in this position despite being
down upon PA and despite having almost
no pieces developed white is it's like
plus one this position which is crazy to
me because if you look at this with kind
of an untrained eye
it looks like for example black can just
push D5 how can black possibly be worse
here but the way I would explain it is
White's position has tremendous
potential energy which is a concept I
haven't like talked about in a while
although white is currently not very
welldeveloped once you push D3 all of
your pieces come alive the Bishops are
nicely aiming at the king side The Rook
can come to E1 with Tempo you're about
to knock the Black Knight to a very
awkward Square
which is going to happen right now
you're going to play A5 forcing the
Knight back to a square where it blocks
the development of the bishop now we can
of course throw in the move Rook E1 okay
let's say black goes Queen C7 and now uh
you can actually start with Knight A3
your knight is aiming for B5 technically
you're sacrificing another Pawn what
happens if black takes it now you open
up the center with D3 well the C4 Pawn
is now hanging so black typically will
take after Queen takes E3 the game is
already over now all of a sudden White's
position is is breathing and if black
pushes E6 there is a simple tactic here
see if you can find it white to play and
cash in on the initiative and the point
of this tactic is to win material white
to play yes very good knight B5 Queen
takes A1 Knight C7 King d8 and now a
very high level detail right you want to
know what high level tactics entail but
this is a great example everybody like
under 2000 automatically plays Bishop G5
just automatic move but black can play
King takes C7 and get the bishop out and
okay black has a rook of piece and what
two pawns for the Queen White is
probably winning here but it's not
convincing but the higher rated players
says wait a second I can actually
Desperado this night I can take take out
the E6 Pawn only now I can play bishop
and this Pawn makes all the difference
why does this Pawn make all the
difference because now E6 is a huge
Target and even visually this looks
completely different like the I guess
the F7 Pawn technically is the one that
is gone and without that pawn black
lacks structural Integrity these pawns
are weak white is it's plus plus five
actually according to the engine which
is why it's a good practice in general
to always pause when you're about to
make an automatic move and I'm not
talking a move that is literally forced
if a move is literally forced it's
stupid to just like think but moves like
Bishop G5 are in the category of
automatic moves where you just assume
that this is the only logical thing to
do this is where you want to pause and
see if you can find a way to slightly
improve the tactic which can be the
difference let's say between a slightly
or clearly better position and a
completely winning position I wish I had
like a readymade example of this and
I'll think about it but I don't for the
moment where were we yeah Queen C7
castles SA sacrificing the E5 Pawn I
think you kind of get the point this A4
idea is super super strong um and you
can find more information in the
chessable course I had a over theboard
game about a year ago against a Chinese
GM xujin cha where he played D6 takes
takes castles Bishop G4 Rook e one so
this is another line that you can
explore uh on your own but here also
white I think is quite a bit
better okay so that is a essentially
Black's options after Bishop C4 our
opponent played a completely different
line which is the immediate D6 and here
again a new idea has been found and it's
this check on B5 that looks very
superficial but as you could see from
the course of the game it actually
contains a very deep idea you're trying
to provoke Bishop D7 and now drop back
to C4 obviously in context of the game
you should be able to understand why
Bishop C4 immediately is bad well bad
for several reasons but the main one is
that black can step back to B6 and again
this trick doesn't work anymore because
black can just duck away to G8 so in
effect you're provoking Bishop D7 and
then dropping back to C4 so you might
ask well what if black doesn't play
Bishop D7 well the only other feasible
move is Knight C6 Knight D7 is very
awkward nobody plays like that if black
plays Knight
C6 then you can castle and again it's
kind of a theme in this line that you
delay the move d4 until the proper
moment moment and here again black is in
quite a bit of trouble so for example if
black plays Bishop D7 now it's finally
time for D4 and Black's position is like
collapsing this Knight is very
vulnerable Black's King side is not
developed it's a really really bad
position if black plays CD you can
actually push C4 very weird idea push C4
Force the Knight back takes takes
develop with Tempo this is at least the
line in my file Bishop
B7 takes or no first you take on
C6 BC takes takes Rook E1 Knight E6
Knight D4 and white is clearly better
castles and you bring out your other
Knight much better by the way than
Knight F5 which would be very greedy
another example of an automatic move
that a lot of people would make and just
forget that after Queen F6 black is
counterattacking B2 you have to
prioritize development and here white is
I would say clearly better better
because black is settled with these two
weaknesses so I've had this exact
sequence quite a few times because it's
relatively
forced and I would say that what this
shows you is that at let's say level
over 2,000 every level over 2,000
learning openings is kind of glamorized
but it shouldn't be like at least 75% of
it is just going through these types of
variations and memorizing them and
understanding them
and then you might ask well are there
any ways that I can help myself memorize
them of course you have to know the
ideas and you have to put in like memory
markers like you have to remember
particularly the unusual ideas that can
help you anchor the line in your memory
for example here the unusual idea is
that when black plays C takes D4 you
actually push C4 you don't see that a
lot in the alipin um so you might tell
yourself okay in this line I have to
remember to push
C4 you can also also tell your like in
this line I have to remember because of
this bishop takes F7 check trick I have
to provoke Bishop D7 which is why I
should give this check first so this
takes some extra work but it can really
help you not forget these lines over the
board okay Bishop D7 Bishop C4 Knight B6
is a mistake the best move in this
position is E6 yeah E6 is the way for
black to equalize but this still leads
to a very exciting position where where
white can
put a lot of practical pressure on black
here the move is D4 and after C takes D4
okay you can do several different things
I forget what the chessable course
actually recommends here you can check
this on your own but one really
interesting idea is actually to Castle
King side if black plays D takes C3 and
continues to eat up pawns then you take
the Knight Bishop D5 e d and now Knight
takes E3 with a huge development
Advantage black center is collap in and
this is how you play the alapin in 2023
takes Bishop G5 you're just continually
ignoring all of Black's pawns that are
hanging and you're prioritizing
development and if black plays F6 here
white to play and deliver a powerful
crushing blow who can spot it 2024 yeah
I said the year wrong Knight takes E5
I'm still making that mistake 18 days
into the year Knight takes E5 I like
moves like that both pieces are hanging
but black can only take the bishop now
Queen H5
here here HG and obviously you don't
take the Rook you take the pawn Knight
takes D5 is mate yeah this line is very
yesterday
exactly so so that's basically the idea
of this line you're prioritizing
development so D takes E3 you take the
bishop uh take the
Knight if black plays well if black
takes the pawn here that I mean this
line is equal but it's it's kind of
dangerous for black like you can play
Knight takes pawn and now again if black
plays Pawn takes Pawn here you can take
twice on D5 and you've got a big double
attack on these two pawns so black has
to know this move Knight B6 this is not
an easy move stepping back to B6 and you
kind of play the Smith MOA style you
just drop your Bishop back and you say
okay you can take my Pawn on C3 but here
I can even throw in the move Queen H5
with a huge initiative G6 obviously the
idea is to step back to F3 and you're
never afraid that black like takes all
of your queenside pawns that's beside
the
point yeah really good line this bishop
B5 check is a very problematic move
black can equalize with careful play but
I mean I would say at all levels below
2500 this is super super challenging
this is why I recommend the alipin to
lower rated players okay so Knight B6
and now Bishop F7 and E6 is a really
sexy trick our opponent played Bishop
takes C6 allowing us to demonstrate the
forest mate of course the relative
lesser evil actually the funny thing is
when you run this on the computer it
says that this is equal but we'll get to
that in a second a lot of people they
get scared and they play King G8 which
is understandable but this position is
just terrible for black now Queen takes
D7 you start by castling okay let's say
black plays Knight C6 here it's a very
good idea to push A4 again familiar idea
A4 if black pushes A5 you can pick up
the Knight with a fork and if black
plays I don't know E6 whatever now you
can push D4 sorry takes takes and then
Knight C3 and then A5 and Rook E1 and
Black's position is just clearly
visually terrible there's not much to
analyze here um so the only testing
testing continuation is to take the pawn
black can also take it with the King and
this paradoxically will transpose into
the game because we're going to do the
same thing we're go Knight G5 and queen
F3 and if black takes on G5 he gets
mated exactly well not exactly like in
the game here you have to know a very
important move which leads to forc mate
and it's actually not H4 the best move
is not H4 it's yes it's Queen F7 and
this type of move is the hardest to find
when you're engaged in a king hunt
because you're tempted to give a bunch
of checks but oftentimes these
restricting moves set set up the mating
net much more effectively than just like
a barrage of checks if you go D4 and get
excited about the discovery the attack
Fizzles out immediately King G6 black
runs away so what you have to do is
block off essentially block off the
escape to F7 and that's it if black
steps back to H6 now you can go D4 and
simple h 4 and then H takes G5 is going
to be mate on the next move and what
this reminds me of this reminds me of a
particular move from a combination that
I've always found very instructive
exactly on this topic and then we'll
probably wrap up let me find the game
this is a very famous game yeah so this
is a game that is featured in a lot of
combination books and it's like a stock
puzzle it's white to play and win petan
finds a combination he actually had this
on the previous move and missed it on
this move he found it and it's simple
it's Queen takes F6 check which kind of
comes to mind King takes F6 Bishop E5
check King G5 this is the instructive
position though this is where a lot of
people slip up especially newer players
um newer players they look at this and
they want to go H4 which is a really bad
move because again it it makes the same
mistake you you actually help the king
Escape same with F4 the move is not Rook
H4 because here black can actually block
off The Rook with H5 but the correct
move is Bishop G7 the same category it's
a quiet move that restricts the Escape
squares and why is this move hard to
find it's kind of because you're down a
queen and you want to play quickly but
it's not like White's King is in any
danger so you're not really in much of a
hurry Bishop G7 finishes immediately
that's forced mate in like two or three
moves so whatever like Bachman res
resigned but like this is
mate guess H4 is probably not no H4
Knight H4 G okay it's mate it's it's
still mate yeah either way there's a
million different mates so this is kind
of the point that I'm trying to
illustrate that when you are engaged
particularly in a king hunt you should
not rush to give the most obvious checks
you should usually start by identifying
the potential Escape Routes and and
seeing if you can make one of those slow
restrictive moves that set up the mating
net um like Queen F7 in our current game
yeah so Queen F7 and and now D4 is okay
the the the computer line is G6 check
okay D3 or D4 now H3 which is a obvious
move you're setting up G4 technically
it's another quiet move but I would say
this is a very straightforward move here
check here Knight D2 and the Knight is
coming to F3 that's it it's made in two
yeah very nice way that the pieces
cooperate in this line you're using
almost everything so anyways that is why
black has to play Bishop F5 now remember
where this came from this came from King
takes C6 our opponent played Bishop B6
but we could have gotten exactly the
same thing if in this position black had
played correctly the move Bishop F5 we
get exactly the same position
interestingly enough and this position
is assessed by the computer as equal
which is obviously a massively
misleading assessment because after
white plays G4 black has a incredibly
difficult defensive task ahead of him
black has to play Ultra accurately here
to maintain the balance so black has to
play E6 here which is not a very
difficult move I mean white is
threatening Maiden one you have to
defend the bishop now you play Knight E4
check you need to throw this move in
forcing the king back to E7 which by the
way is another semi- difficult move King
F7 is much worse because you take and
now you have Queen H5 check so black has
no King E7 okay he play G takes F5 this
still looks terrible for black but it
turns out that after EF5 Queen F5 Queen
D7 White's it's not like White's attack
Fizzles out White's attack continues you
drop your queen back black plays Knight
C6 you play D4 opening up the bishop but
if black plays this super accurately he
can keep the balance CD now you're
actually not supposed to play Bishop G5
check you're supposed to recapture now
we're getting into like computer the
Theory which is not very interesting nor
very instructive for most people it's
enough to remember to give this check
and then to meet Bishop F5 with G4 and
then it's important to remember this
move Knight E4 and that's enough you
don't really need to remember anything
else okay if your opponent has done his
homework done their homework and knows
like an 18 move line and equalizes
congrats but this is this is chess like
this is going to be true of every
opening that you play by the way
if black plays G6 here that's actually
losing because after GF GF you can go
Queen H5 and suddenly you're coming
around to F7 black can't stop that so E6
also not a given the black black knows
um of course you might be watching this
as a beginner and saying well isn't all
of this unnecessary like how is this
going to help me at all and yes I mean
the the theory itself might not be
directly helpful but hopefully you still
find the lines like entertaining and
when you get stronger they're going to
help you but you know we're at a high
level in the speedrun so I'm kind of
tailoring the theory to higher rated
players but yeah King takes G5 obviously
forced mate the prettier line though is
King G6 this is the prettier line here
and this is what I was trying to
remember after H5 King H6 actually white
has to find Queen E3 check which is easy
once you get to this position but the
temptation to play D4 is extremely
strong but D4 squanders the whole
Advantage black plays G5 you take on pan
and black escapes to G7 with just a
completely unclear position there's no
mate if you go Bishop H6 the King has
escaped all the way back to G8 and we're
screwed um so actually the correct move
is Queen E3 forking the bishop and the
King G5 takes and a beautiful mate
H6 yeah this is a gorgeous line in
general this is really really nice this
bishop F7
line just aesthetically aesthetically
very pretty so this is great good stuff
to remember this can win you a bunch of
games and it won us this game okay our
opponent played King H6 here of course
again again D4 is very very bad so
weirdly enough you actually don't play
this discovered check often here again
black plays G5 Boom the king escapes to
G7 and we're in trouble so here the
correct move is Queen F4 and okay
obviously you get made in one
so yeah so clearly this guy was 2340 I
mean uh just didn't know the line and
figured that I was bluffing and went for
it too quickly and got checkmated and
this is why you know like if you really
want to supercharge your improvement as
someone who doesn't have a lot of time
to invest in chess but let's say you're
like 17
1800 this is the benefit of like
learning a chessable coures you you're
going to win countless games like this
and you might say well is this really in
the spirit of improvement like why not
since the resources exist you might as
well capitalize on them so it was a very
short game perhaps some people are not
very satisfied but I think we converted
it into a semi instructive analysis
session which was focused on Theory but
hopefully you found it instructive
obviously we didn't cover the E6
variations like if black plays E6 and
again if black plays D6 this is a whole
separate line black also has the move B6
which is a very reputable sideline so
this doesn't cover the extent of the
Knight F6 variation um there's a lot of
theory in the alipin that you have to
know but not as much as in the open
Sicilian it's far from as overwhelming
as let's say learning Knight F3 and D4
which I don't recommend to anybody I
think the alapin is far more practical
to learn in a couple of weeks and
hopefully with the aid of the
speedrun okay this is where we will end
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
hanging out see you guys
[Music]
soon